in this video we'll talk about the
chromosome organization
this video is slightly long but stay
tuned till the end of this video because
you can learn many things which are not
described well in the books or not
available in any other part of the
internet
so how does chromosome look like when we
think about chromosome these kind of X
shaped structure Flash in our mind so
this is a classical chromosome well it's
not incorrect but this is more
appropriately said as a metaphysic
chromosome
that simply means chromosome looks very
different in different stages of cell
cycle
like an interface they have appearance
like these generally beads on string in
prophase Things become more complicated
and chromosome is now more densely
packed whereas in metaphase
the chromosome looks like that
characteristic x-shaped structure
so a different time point in the cell
cycle chromosome would look very
different so overall the appearance of
chromosome is highly Dynamic just like
you don't look similar when you are a
teenager versus a young person or even a
mature person chromosome doesn't look
the same always
so let's look at the level of chromosome
organization
at the simplest level we can see
nucleosomes nucleosomes are combination
of DNA and histone proteins
and histone is wrapped around the
histones are actually wrapped by the DNA
histones are basic proteins which has
lysine and Arginine like basic amino
acids
and they are found in the nucleus there
are canonical histones such as
h3h4 h2a h2b they combine with each
other forming dimers eventually that
dimers associate forms tetramer and
ultimately uh histone octamar is
generated
so each of these histones are repeated
twice in an histone octoma
so overall the octomar look like a ball
and the DNA is wrapping around it so
this is known as the nucleosomal DNA
there are interaction between the
histone and the DNA the DNA is
negatively charged due to the presence
of phosphate group and the histone is
positively charged due to the presence
of basic amino acids such as lysine and
arginine
so around 200 base pairs of DNA is
wrapped around 1.6 left-handed super
helical turns around these histone
octomas this is called nucleosome or the
basic unit of chromosome
at the simplest organization
the chromosome shows a beads on string
appearance
and majorly these beads on string
structures are predominant in the
interphase
there are also other structures such as
the 30 nanometer fiber
the 13 nanometer fibers are bit more
complicated and they are a bit more
organized there are H1 histones which
helps formation of these kind of 30
nanometer structure the most common
model of 30 nanometer structure is the
solenoid model and this is characterized
by interaction between consecutive
nucleosome here in this model any
nucleosome n interacts with n plus one
number of nucleosome
there are also zigzag model
it implies the interaction between
alternate nucleosome that means in and N
plus 2 and it doesn't interact with n
plus 1 in this particular model
still people don't know which model is
actually found inside the nucleus all
these data all these models are based on
in vitro data still scientists debate on
Which models are predominant each model
has their advantages and disadvantages
in terms of explaining the structure
however there are other level of
organizations which are more complicated
such as the 300 nanometer fiber here
several such uh beads on string
structure assembles on a scaffold to
form a more complicated more packed and
condensed chromatin structure
so there are several levels of chromatin
structure but we have to understand at
any point of time we don't get all these
organization depend on which cell cycle
phase we are looking at we would see
chromosome in different Outlook
so question is what factors determine
chromatin condensation in some stage of
cell division you see chromatins are
more condensed and forming that accept
chromosome which molecular factors are
responsible for this
one such molecular factors are cohesives
and condensins as the name suggests they
help in condensation and cohesion of
these nucleosome structures
and these proteins are important for
maintenance of chromosome structure
for chromatin compaction and
condensation of the chromatin so the 300
nanometer fiber is supported by several
cohesine and condensing Rings eventually
the metaphase chromosome has several of
these these proteins
but when
the chromat chromatins need to be
separated in the anaphase
there are specific mechanisms and
specific molecular players which break
down these cohesive rings
and once this cohesion rings are broken
down chromatin can be pulled on the two
opposite pole with the microtubules and
they can be separated in the anaphase
stage
most of the picture that we know about
chromatin today comes from electron
microscopy studies in early 1970s
from the electrode microscopy studies
people found out that there are specific
region inside the cell which are densely
stained they are known as
heterochromatin and there are specific
regions which are lightly stained or
having less electron density then named
as
euchrementing
so now we know more about the molecular
basis of euchromatin or heterochromatin
formation
but this simply came from the
observation of electron microscopy
studies
so the entire 10 nanometer string
structure is generally transcriptionally
active
so there are specific region of the
overall beads on string structure which
are more active
they are part of the euchromatin
classical definition of euchromatin and
there are specific regions which are
transcriptionally inactive question is
what are the factors that determines
this differential response
there could be specific modifications
present in the histone in that
nucleosomes which can change the
chromatin accessibility
there could be different variants of
histone there could be nucleosome
remodeling complex that alters the
positioning and the composition of
nucleosome there could be DNA
methylation that change the
accessibility of DNA or wrapping around
the histones all these possibilities are
there so if we look at a heterochromatin
versus euchromatin we can appreciate
that in the heterochromatin
the the region which are densely packed
it is less acetylated whereas
euchromatin is Loosely packed and it is
highly highly acetylated so several uh
modifications of the histone determines
what is the status of nuclear of the
chromosome and the euchromatin is
transcriptionally active whereas
heterochromatin is inactive
but how molecular molecular aspect can
discriminate between these two
structures so there could be different
histone modifications histone variants
or even differences in DNA methylation
in these regions
coming to the histone modifications
there are several digital modifications
which are pro-ecrementin
that means that increases the
accessibility make the chromosome lose
these kind of modifications are
acetylation there are several residues
which can be acetylated most common ones
are h3k9 acetylation h3k 27 acetylation
Etc there are methylations which can
also be activatory such as h3k4me2 or
h3k36me3 there are phosphorylation which
are also also associated with
euchromatin H3 is S10 phosphorylation is
a pretty common one which is associated
with euchromatin or transcriptionally
active chromatin
in contrast in heterochromatin there are
specific methylation patterns which are
peculiar to these regions and which
further helps in chromatin compaction
there are specific histone variants
which discriminate between different
chromatin regions
so in euchromatin one can find h2se in
the transcription start site and one can
find H 3.3 along the gene body promoters
or regulatory elements of a
transcriptionally active Gene so the
histone composition of the nucleosome
can also determine the chromatin state
or status of transcription in a cell
heterochromatin Associated variants
include H 3.1 3.2 simp a which is also a
H3 variant macro h2a Etc so all these
things lead to chromatin compaction
instead of opening up the chromatin so
differences in histone composition
histone modification all can determine
how what is the organization of overall
chromosome there are also H1 histone
variants which are very peculiar to the
heterochromatic region in heterogromatin
region one might expect H1 to be present
more H1 Associated nucleosome attracts
specific components such as suvar
complex that leads to recruitment of
protein molecules which leads to
heterochromagnization
now question is
um there are other aspects of difference
such as methylation it has been found
that hypermethylated regions are mostly
associated with heterochromatin whereas
hypomethylated ones are associated with
euchromatin so overall accessibility in
the chromatin is super important for
transcription if the transcription
Factor transcription Machinery doesn't
get
this in the chromosome how would
transcript transcription happen the
metaphysic chromosome is mostly
transcriptionally inactive because it is
densely packed it is good for
segregation of the chromosome not good
for other molecular biology processes
so let's talk about what are the
regulation regulatory elements of
Chromatin accessibility
so nucleosome remodeling factors are the
key players determining chromatin
accessibility
these big complexes work on the base of
ATP and they can also bind to specific
acetylated residues with the help of
bromodomain or methylated residues with
the help of chromodomin so once they
interact with the chromatin it can do
many things nucleosome remodeling
complexes can lead to free up of his
toner they can kick out some histones
from a nucleosome that is known as
histone eviction
histone eviction leads to accessibility
of a new site in the DNA where let's say
RNA polymerase or transcription factors
can bind
there are other mechanisms where a
stone is
different histone variant this is known
as histone replacement
especially the genes that are undergoing
active transcription in that case the
nucleosome associated is replaced by H
3.3 histone variant
there are other methods as well
where the nucleosomes can be relatively
slide far apart from each other freeing
up new DNA segments in between them this
is known as nucleosome sliding it
doesn't kick out the histone but Slide
the histone push it away from its normal
endogenous place and freeing up new DNA
region where other proteins can bind and
do their job
now these kind of Chromatin
accessibility can be studied at a global
level with the high throughput
technology known as attack sequencing if
you want more details about attack
sequencing you can click on my video but
8X sequencing and attack sequencing
Peaks would tell us whether a chromatin
region is more accessible or less
accessible
the video link is provided in the I
button or description
let's talk about the 3D organization of
Chromatin we have to understand
chromosome is not flattened in a 2d
space chromosome is actually organized
in the 3D Volume inside the nucleus
so inside the nucleus chromosome has
specific domains
so these are known as chromosome
territories
so here we can see
that there are specific chromosome
territories
now if we zoom into the chromosome
territories there are topologically
associated domains which come closer in
a 3D space
so there could be intra chromosomal
interactions or inter-chromosomal
interaction imagine there is a loop
inside that marked in yellow where two
locations such as point a and point B
were very far apart from each other in a
linear space but they come closer to
each other in a 3D Volume
same goes for two different chromosome
here the blue chromosome and the yellow
chromosome are different but one Loop of
this yellow chromosome comes closer to
the blue chromosome that is why two
particular points which are X and Y
which are actually very separate in a
linear space they are even present in
different chromosomes but they can also
come close together and interact with
each other this is how promoter
interacts with enhancer forming new
promoter enhancer loops and these kind
of topologically associated domain
brings out the fine-tuned regulation of
transcription
so let's say here is a linear
configuration where the promoter is
three kilobase pairs away from the
enhancer region
but imagine a looping event happening
which brings out these three kilos per
enhancer close to the promoter and now
RNA polymerase and specific other
transcription Factor can be recruited
can be interacted with each other to
give rise to the transcription and this
is how 3D chromatin concept is really
important
now 3D chromatin conformation can be
captured using methods like high C or
chroma chromatin confirmation techniques
here specific regions of the chromatin
who are interacting with each other
are frozen in a particular point of time
Point using cross-linking reagent later
on these portions are fragmented and
sequenced that tells us okay which
particular portions in the genome has
actually interacted in a 3D chromatin
conformation
so this gives us an overall interaction
or a contact map that looks like these
pyramidant triangle each of that has
meaning to it in a different video we'll
talk about it which would be also linked
in the I button
anyway so looking at these high C map
and looking at it in different
resolution one can understand how
chromosome chromosomes are interacting
with each other how how there is like
intra chromosome interaction and Inter
chromosome interaction one can look at a
very zoomed out View and looked at the
chromosome territories and this
correlation Matrix shows exactly that
one can look in a bit more zoomed in
view
in a 10 kilobase pair resolution one can
look at how chromatin compartments are
interacting with each other
at a very much zoomed in view one can
understand how specific intra
chromosomal regions are forming loops
and coming close in time and space
so all these correlation Matrix has
their own meaning which would be
described in different video in much
more details but 3D chromating is a
highly Dynamic entity that means if you
imagine a Time t 0 you can see the
particular A and B genomic points are
closed in time and space
but if you imagine a Time t equal to T1
these two region might go far away
also this can happen at a
inter-chromosomal level
right there could be new introduction
there could be
a resolution of old interactions
so imagine in in a inter-chromosomal
interaction the point X and Y are
interacting between these two chromosome
it might turn out that at time T1 these
interaction is resolved and new Loops
are formed so these are all
possibilities so overall in these videos
we we learned that we learned about how
chromosome is different and how the
structural organization of chromosome is
different at a different level what
factors determine chromatin organization
we looked at histone modifications DNA
modifications and also histone variants
that can change the organization of
chromosome chromosome and actually
uh ensures that okay what are you
chromatin and what are heterochromatin
it can give us a molecular handle to
understand these two transcriptionally
different structures also we looked at
the concept and I introduced you to the
concept of 3D chromatin and we talked
about how this chromating is dynamic in
time and space you can get more
flashcards and notes in my Facebook page
you can follow my Instagram page which
is right now here links are in the
description
you can support our Channel using super
thanks and see you in next video